noch 155 Tage bis zum 8 oktober bis zum
Schließen der Wahllokale für die
landtags- und bezirkstagswahl ungefähr
noch
3.728 Stunden liebe Freundin Freunde ab
heute starten wir in den Vorwahlkampf
das wird ein langer Marathon mit
foldampf die Ausgangslage für diese
wichtige Entscheidung für Bayern ist
besser als 2018 und viel besser als nach
2021 die CSU hat sich wieder
stabilisiert die Partei ist motiviert
die Mitgliederzahlen wachsen wieder wir
haben unsere Mitte gefunden mit uns mit
den Bayern wir sind wieder so nah bei
den Menschen wie lange nicht und daher
ist unser klares Ziel für den 8 Oktober
wir wollen diese Landtagswahl gewinnen
liebe Freunde und Freunde das ist unser
Anspruch
die Alternative liegt klar auf dem Tisch
entweder bayernkoalition oder Ampel
entweder souveränes regieren wie in
Bayern oder dauerzoff- und Streit wie in
Berlin entweder eine abgehobene
Regierung die unser Land umerziehen will
oder eine bodenständige Staatsregierung
die für die normalen Leute da ist ich
sage euch eins Bayern hat etwas besseres
als eine Ampel verdient liebe Freundin
unser Land braucht eine Regierung die
für Bayern da ist die Bayern nicht
benachteiligt sondern für Bayern kämpft
die den einzigartigen Charakter des
Freistaats Bayern erhält und deswegen
wollen wir eine bürgerliche liberale
bodenständige Staatsregierung
Unterführung der CSU und keine wie immer
geartete Ampel das was in Berlin nicht
funktioniert soll es auch in Bayern auf
keinen Fall geben liebe Freunde das ist
unsere Aufgabe
wir beschließen heute ein neues
Grundsatzprogramm was auf die Basis für
das Wahlprogramm ist wir wollen zeigen
was wir den letzten fünf Jahren
geleistet haben und was wir für die
nächsten fünf Jahre in Bayern Vorhaben
wir reden Klartext wofür steht die CSU
und wofür steht sie nicht es gibt
nämlich Unterschiede und zwar
grundsätzlicher Art es ist nicht egal
wer regiert neben dem Programm wollen
wir noch mal klar machen dass auch die
Realität zählt Programme werden viel
erdacht aber was ist die Realität zum
Beispiel wie man große Krisen meistert
und auch wenn jeder denkt alles ist
schon vorbei ich will nur eines sagen
wir haben nicht schlimmste
Herausforderung für unser Land seit den
Zweiten Weltkrieg gemeinsam gemeistert
das war Corona am Ende haben wir über
130.000 Leben gerettet den Mittelstand
beschützt es waren harte Zeiten es waren
harte Entscheidungen es tut mir leid ist
nicht jede Verordnung die allerbeste
sein mag aber liebe Freunde wir haben
uns nicht weggedrückt wir sind nicht
weggelaufen wir haben unbequeme aber
notwendige Entscheidung und zur Rettung
und des Landes getroffen und am Ende
unter dem Strich sagen 70 Prozent der
Bayern es haben Sie eigentlich ganz gut
gemacht ich will euch nur eines sagen
wer in solch schweren Zeiten den
führungs den Krisen den Charaktertest
besteht den kann man auch die Zukunft
anvertrauen Dank an euch alle dass wir
das gemeinsam für unser Land geschultert
und durchgestanden haben liebe Freunde
trotz zweier fundamentaler Krisen wie
noch nie ist die Bilanz nach fünf Jahren
eigentlich sehr positiv bei eines
starkenie und Bayern ist beliebt wie nie
es gibt keine Flucht aus Bayern sondern
Zuwachs 90% der Menschen leben gern in
Bayern und wenn man Menschen in anderen
Bundesländern fragt wo sie gern leben
möchten anstatt in ihrer Heimat sagen
nahezu alle wenn ich woanders leben
möchte dann in Bayern bei uns lebt man
länger bei uns lebt man glücklicher und
wir sind in jeder Statistik auf Platz
eins oder zwei Bayern ist und bleibt
Zukunft und Sehnsuchtsort und liebe den
Freundinnen Freunde das ist kein Zufall
oder irgendwie so passiert neben dem
Fleiß der Menschen waren es die
richtigen Weichenstellungen Politik und
wer hat es gemacht das waren wir die CSU
liebe Freunde wir machen es auch weiter
unsere Leitsätze in unsere Ziele für die
nächsten fünf Jahre erstens wir wollen
Wohlstand für alle und zwar dauerhaft
man muss es sich leisten leben zu können
und man muss von harter Arbeit gut leben
können und nicht nur die oberen 10.000
wir sind für die Mitte da für die
Normalverdiener für die sogenannten
kleinen Leute für Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer für Mittelstand Handwerk
Landwirtschaft und auch für die vielen
Rentnerinnen Rentner die unser Land
aufgebaut haben es bleibt der Satz der
immer gegolten hat die CSU ist nicht die
Kaviar sondern die leberkäseetage liebe
Freundinnen Freunde dafür sind wir da
für die ganz normalen Leute in unserem
Land
zweitens
wir wollen eine gute Zukunft für unsere
jungen für Kinder für zu Enkel wir
wollen uns sein Land Kinder und Enkel
Fest für die Zukunft machen deswegen ist
beste Betreuung Schule Ausbildung
Forschung für uns ein ganz zentraler
Bestandteil die Vereinbarkeit von
Familie und Beruf die Qualität in der
Schule und Forschung von Weltrang ist
ganz entscheidend ich sage euch eins
auch wenn es manch einer gar nicht
wahrhaben will Bildung Familie und
Betreuung hat für uns absolute
Prioritäten ein gutes Leben macht man
nur mit der Familie und jede Familie
erwartet dabei die Leistung das wollen
wir in Bayern das wollen wir als Jesu
geben liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
drittens wir wollen das Bayern sicher
und solide bleibt Bayern hat die
niedrigste Kriminalitätsrate in
Deutschland dank unserer Polizei das ist
aber auch kein Zufall sondern wir haben
in den ganzen Jahren die Bestand der
Polizei ausgetauscht verstärkt wir
stehen hinter der Polizei wir stehen in
der Sicherheitskräfte mit der Bundeswehr
wir danken unseren Feuerwehren und allen
Wohlfahrts und Rettungsorganisation für
ein Einsatz und deswegen sage ich ganz
klar in Bayern wird es keine Kreuzberger
Nächte geben liebe Freunde das ist unser
Anspruch
ganz sicher und solide wir bleiben
finanziell solide wir sind ein
triple-eland wir sind gegen das Schulden
machen und für die Schuldenbremse wir
sind gegensteuererhöhung und für
Entlastung der Bürger solide Finanzen
ist der absolute Markenkern der CSU wir
können mit Geld umgehen liebe Freunde
und sichern das Vermögen der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger
[Applaus]
viertens vorletztes zu den Grundsätzen
natürlich wollen wir nachhaltiges Bayern
wir wollen den Erhalt der einzigartigen
Natur Bayerns und die Bewahrung der
Schöpfung wir schützen Wälder Berge
sehen ganz besonders unser Trinkwasser
und auch die Artenvielfalt wir sagen ja
zum Klimaschutz aber nein das
klimaklebern liebe Freunde und wir
wollen Landwirtschaft und ländliche Raum
erhalten manch eine Glauben der
ländliche Raum sei ein Museum wir sagen
der ländliche Raum ist zukunftsraum er
ist die Seele Bayerns und keiner steht
so für den Erhalt der ländlichen Räume
wie die CSU ob in Bayern oder
Deutschland liebe Freunde
und fünftens und letztens wir wollen die
bayerische Kultur die bayerische
Lebensart ihre Einzigartigkeit erhalten
deswegen sind wir gegen unerziehung und
für Freiheit wir sind gegenwächs sondern
für die liberale tastbar Ware und es
bleibt der Kernsatz und wenn wir auch
dafür angegriffen werden und manche kann
etwas anders möchten Bayern ist ein
Freistaat und wir wollen Freistaat
bleiben und kein Verbots oder
Zwangsstaat werden liebe Freunde dafür
stehen wir Gemeinschaft
zum ersten zum Wohlstand liebe
Freundinnen Freunde den Wohlstand für
die normalen Leute zu erhalten wird die
größte Aufgabe überhaupt
auch wenn es viele Sorgen gibt das stand
jetzt könnte ja ganz einfach sein wir
sind im Moment stärker als je zuvor
Bayern ist die sechs größte
Volkswirtschaft in der Europäischen
Union unser Bruttoinlandsprodukt ist
größer als 90% in der Welt wir haben die
meisten Industriearbeitsplätze in
Deutschland denn die niedrigste
Arbeitslosenquote in Deutschland mit die
niedrigste Jugendarbeitslosigkeit in
ganz Europa wir haben die niedrigste
Armutsgefährdung die meisten
Dax-Unternehmen und die meisten Meister
im Handwerk jetzt können wir sagen alles
gut aber es muss mal anhören ja schon
eine Bilanz liebe Freunde wer in
Deutschland hat solch eine Bilanzen
Bayern ich kenne kein Land
aber wir spüren es doch die Menschen
sind unsicher und der Wohlstand in
Deutschland schwankt das Wohlstands Eis
schmilzt schneller als das Eis der
Gletscher
wir können viel in Bayern tun aber da
wir nicht selbständig sind jedenfalls
auf absehbare Zeit ja
sind wir auch von den Weichenstellungen
in Berlin betroffen lieber Alexander die
Ampel ist leider das kann man jetzt
sagen haben wir beide halb
Halbzeitbilanz die Amt ist leider
Hauptverursacher und das trifft auch uns
in Bayern und ich sage natürlich ist die
Situation nach der Ukraine schwierig
aber die Wahrheit ist doch der jetzige
Verlust von Wohlstand und der jetzige
Abstiegssorgen der Mitte hängen mit
einer Reihe von Fehlentscheidungen der
Ampel zusammen liebe Freunde und Freunde
die Ampel wird mit dem was sie tut mit
dem was sie will und mit dem was sie
beschließt am Ende zum größten
Armutsrisiko der jüngeren deutschen
Geschichte liebe Freunde
jetzt loben sich alle ja wir haben den
Winter geschafft naja in dem Wetter
Liebe von Freunde aber Wahrheit ist doch
es bleibt bei dauerhaften Huhn viel zu
hohen Energiepreisen und einer dauerhaft
viel zu hohen Inflation
das
Fristen von wirtschaften und Bürgern
Stück für Stück auf lange können das
alle nicht durchhalten
ich zeige euch eins zum Thema Energie
natürlich sind erneuerbare Energien die
Zukunft wir ich persönlich wir tun alles
um Bayern dazu stärken und auf die
Zukunft gut vorzubereiten entgegen
diesen ganzen narrativen die immer
wieder gemacht werden Bayern sei da
schlecht ist es quasi notariell belegt
das Bayern jetzt schon sehr sehr gut ist
bei der installierten Leistung
erneuerbare Energien sind wir das größte
Land in Deutschland der Zubau 2022 23
waren wir klar Nummer eins
25% von allem was neu an erneuerbaren
Energien in Deutschland war kam aus
Bayern wir haben das Ziel des bis 2030
natürlich zu verdoppeln wir sind
übrigens überall die Nummer eins bis auf
Wind da komme ich gleich dazu bei
Photovoltaik gibt es derzeit fast
800.000 Anlagen in Bayern
28% der deutschen Photovoltaik stehen wo
in Bayern bei staatlichen Dächern sind
wir klar die Nummer 1 übrigens ungefähr
umgerechnet bedeutet die Leistung der
Photovoltaik in Bayern ungefähr 2000
Windräder
wir bauen das jetzt aus
Agrar Photovoltaik Dächer ausbauen
Autobahnen über Polter und Mode wir
nutzen jede Gelegenheit Photovoltaik zu
entwickeln wir sind bei Wasser absoluter
Spitzenreiter das wird derzeit an Wasser
an Strom erzeugen die wir vorhin Freunde
entspricht übrigens auch 2000 Rennräder
von der Leistung aber das reicht uns
nicht wir wollen mehr
Pumpspeicherkraftwerke in Ried und
Hamburg wir wollen neue große Kraftwerke
an der Salzach wir reden mit den
Österreichern darüber und die ersten
Gespräche sind sehr mutigend und ja wenn
der Bund
Wasserkraftwerke dir derzeit im Eigentum
hält verkaufen würde dann wollen wir
nicht dass irgendwelche Investoren die
kaufen dann sind wir offen dafür ein
sage ich euch
wenn man Biomasse noch ein weiterer
wichtiger Energieträger wenn man
Photovoltaik und Wasserkraft
zusammenzählt hat Bayern Stromerzeugung
ungefähr so viel wie 5000 Windräder
allein nur mal zum Vergleich ich glaube
nur Niedersachsen hat mehr Windräder
drum ist diese ganze Debatte die geführt
wird insbesondere von den Grünen Bayern
sei schlecht von erneuerbaren Energien
nur ein billiges Ablenkungsmanöver aus
schlechtem Gewissen liebe Freunde keiner
kann das Reisen was wir dazu tun
und natürlich bauen wir auch Wind aus
wir haben 10h überarbeitet lieber Thomas
Kreuzer der Fraktion danke für die gute
Zusammenarbeit wir machen Windparks in
Chemiedreieck bei Wacker Südost
Oberbayern für die Glasindustrie in
Oberfranken wir öffnen den Staatswald
und wollen auch eine eigene Gesellschaft
Bayern Wind machen um selbst auch dort
Windräder mitzubauen damit nicht nur
irgendwelche Investoren dabei Geld
verdienen liebevollen Freunde aber eines
sage ich euch obwohl wir so viel machen
wie nie und obwohl wir mehr machen als
andere ist es ein Irrglaube zu hoffen
dass damit alle Probleme beseitigt sind
es wird so nicht reichen um die
grundlastfähigkeit zu schaffen und
deswegen ist und bleibt es ein
fundamentaler weitreichender Fehler für
die Wirtschaft und für die Bürger
Deutschlands die Kernkraftwerke
abzuschalten den Strom für 10 Millionen
Haushalten wegfallen zu lassen die
Grünen tun das nicht aus Gemeinwohl
Interessen sondern aus reiner Ideologie
liebe Freunde nichts anderes steht da
dahinter
beweise es geht den Grünen nicht ums
Klima denn sonst könnten sie nicht als
Ersatz Kohle wollen allein der Ersatz
durch Kohle von Kernkraft bedeutet
ungefähr so viel wie den CO2-Ausstoß von
30% des deutschen Pkw-Verkehrs es geht
in grün auch nicht um die Sicherheit der
Kraftwerke denn zum einen haben sie
nichts dagegen dass ersatzstrom aus
Frankreich und Tschechien kommt und
besonders albern war der Auftritt von
herrnweg in der Ukraine liebe Freunde ja
ich stelle mir vor wenn ich sowas
gemacht oder einer von euch sowas
gemacht hätte wie unsere Medien und die
uns ohnehin liebevoll pflegen vielen
Dank dafür aber wie sie uns da behandeln
würden
man geht in die Ukraine und sagt dann so
beiläufig euer klar die Dinger stehen
schon da kann man sie auch laufen lassen
also wenn ich die gleiche these anwandt
Wende die Dinger stehen schon da kann
man sie laufen lassen dann frage ich
mich was der Unterschied sein soll
zwischen Kernkraftwerken in der Ukraine
und Deutschland und man möge es mir
verzeihen so richtig das Gefühl das kann
Energie in der Ukraine generell sicherer
und werden Kriegszeiten noch sicherer
wäre im Vergleich seit einem seit 35
Jahren störungsfrei laufenden Isa 2 kann
ich nicht erkennen sorry das ist
eindeutige Doppelmoral und der
Doppelmoral hat soll endlich von seinem
hohen moralischen Ross heruntersteigen
liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
und auch wenn es das etablierte Berlin
ist nicht bei uns ist wir verstehen die
general über Alex auch überhaupt nicht
hören will
zu schalten lassen
registerkrieg vorbei ist bis die Brücke
zu den erneuerbaren Energien geschafft
ist und bis es zu spät ist liebe
Freundinnen Freunde kein Land der Welt
macht es die Finnen immer Gegner setzen
darauf die Japaner die Fukushima erlebt
haben machen es und wir führen Debatten
darüber ob es denn nicht schlimm sei
weil wir vor zehn elf Jahren in einer
anderen Zeit bei anderen Krisen bei
anderen Herausforderungen eine andere
Entscheidung getroffen haben Politiker
die nicht auf Krisen reagieren können
Parteien die nicht pragmatisch auf die
Herausforderung der Zeit zu reagieren
die haben keinen Anspruch regieren zu
dürfen liebe Freunde lasst sie
weiterlaufen
[Applaus]
wir setzen übrigens danach auch
erneuerbare aber auch auf neue
Technologien auch im Kernbereich neue
Forschung es gibt echte Durchbrüche bei
der neuen Kernfusion nicht bei der alten
die seit 50 Jahren kämpft es gibt
Riesenchancen in den USA gibt es erste
Hinweise von Firmen die das machen
können ein völlig neues Energie
Zeitalters möglich und was macht die
Bundesregierung was machen Teile der
Grünen sagen nein auf keinen Fall wir
machen da nicht mit wir werden auf
Kernfusion setzen wir werden uns
erforschen wir werden und planen einen
neuen Forschungsreaktor in Garching und
ich höre schon wieder wie die Grünen der
Gegend sind und eins kann ich an das
sagen was mir immer auffällt wenn es um
keiner geht
flippengrüne vor Freude aus aber überall
wurde das Wort Kern drauf steht da
kriegen sie sofort Pickel liebe Freunde
so kann man die Zukunft Deutschlands
nicht verschlafen
[Applaus]
diese Energiepolitik die ist übrigens
nicht zum Schaden nur von Deutschland
sondern sie haben noch ein besonderen
Dreher gegen den Süden gegen Bayern und
wenn ich es genauso auch gegen
Baden-Württemberg auch hier Belege klar
das starke und hervorragende Bundesland
Nordrhein-Westfalen erhält
ersatzgaskraftwerke indem man sagt wenn
aus der Kohle ausgestiegen wird 2030
kriegt ihr grundlastträgersatzkraftwerke
bei uns hat kein Anruf keine SMS noch
kein Angebot gegeben als Ersatz Gaskraft
zwei der billig wasserstoffnetze wir
sind fast das einzige Bundeslandes
jedenfalls zu viel Macht beim Thema
Wasserstoff eigene Strategie fast eine
Milliarde investiert Industrieprojekte
Tankstellen eigene Pipelines und
elektrolyseure diese
wasserstoffkraftwerke das größte ist
übrigens derzeit in Europa ein Wunsiedel
wir bauen 50 davon in ganz Deutschland
der Bund aber sagt
Wasserstoff muss von Norden gebaut
werden erst irgendwann im Süden das
heißt das gesamte industrielle
Leistungs-
die Nordländer haben begonnen da habe
ich diesen Fan davon
Wirtschaftsministerium unterstützt ist
in Berlin sie wollen unterschiedliche
strompreiszonen einführen mit dem Ziel
im Norden soll der Strom deutlich
billiger werden und im Süden deutlich
teurer
man glaubt damit den Norden zu stärken
und den Süden zu schwächen ich sage euch
eines das wird ein nationales Eigentor
glaubt jemand echt das BMW deswegen nach
Buxtehude Audi nach Amrum oder wacker
nach Wacken wandert liebe Freunde und
Freunde dies ist ein fehlerspeichertes
Land und zeigt nur die haben von
Deutschland und Wirtschaftspolitik null
Ahnung liebe Freunde null Ahnung Null
Kompetenz
jetzt muss man zu Entschuldigung von den
habe ich sagen dass er sich das glaube
ich gar nicht ausgedacht hat er ist ja
ein erfolgreicher Kinderbuchautor
und hat sich dann als Ergänzungen der
Kompetenz jemand gehört sein Hirn in der
Energiepolitik ist dieser mittlerweile
legen der bekannte staatsse der reichen
der Staatssekretär der die Vereinbarkeit
von Familie Berufe deutlich falsch
verstanden hat liebevollen Freunde
es ist unglaublich
die ganze grüne Sippe wird da irgendwie
beschäftigt liebe Freunde
NGOs Verwandtschaft gehen ein und aus
Trauzeugen Bruder Schwester Onkel Tante
wir werden dann durch weiter schauen
sicherlich auch jeden Schwippschwager
noch finden ja es sieht übrigens so aus
wie vergleichbar bei einer anderen
Veranstaltung die gerade im Moment
stattfindet wenn ja genialogische
Stammbäume sieht dann sieht man auch wer
wann mit wem da irgendwo verwandt ist
das ist nichts anderes als grüne
Korruption liebe Freunde nichts anderes
habe ich muss reichen entlassen sonst
ist die verwandtenaffäre Reichen eine
Affäre Habeck und ich sag das mal
deutlicher manche grünen Bayerischen
Landtag wenn ihr noch einmal das Wort
Filz ernsthaft in den Mund nimmt löst
eure eigenen Probleme anstatt
ratschläger den anderen zu geben
wisst ihr was mich auch an dieser
Debatte um diese stromzonen Strompreise
ärgert
ist die Frage der kommt oder der
Eindruck die Bayern bereichern sich auf
Kosten der Republik und der Armen
natländer oder tolle Leute gibt wenn das
so stimmen würde dann hätte ich ein
schlechtes Gewissen
der Länderfinanzausgleich er ist der
pcr-tester Ehrlichkeit und
Leistungsfähigkeit ja der sagt doch was
ganz anderes
seit mehr als 14 Jahren
zahlt Bayern allein mehr als 50% des
Länderfinanzausgleichs manche Haushalte
in Norddeutschland werden zum Teil zu
zehn Prozent aus dem
Länderfinanzausgleich gedeckt Bayern
zahlt derzeit sogar 60% 10 Milliarden
für alle die irgendwelche Wünsche haben
10 Milliarden bedeutet ungefähr
kostenlose Kita für 600.000 Kinder fast
400.000 geförderte Pflegeplätze fast
150.000 Lehrkräfte wenn man sie alle
hätten und zweimal eine Stammstrecke mit
einer Minibar an jedem Platz liebevollen
Freunde sorry
wir zahlen ja echt gern und wir helfen
gerne zu viel und wenn man dafür da noch
beschimpft wird und wenn man dann noch
angegriffen wird anstatt dass jemand mal
so bisschen danke sagt habt ihr das im
privaten Leben irgendwo erlebt dass ihr
jemand alles gibt was er hat und
trotzdem macht er euch nieder ich sag
mal eines
ich habe gestern bei der Veranstaltung
dieses warum machen andere Länder lieber
Christian dann Reiter einen 29 € Ticket
für alle ja das können die aber nicht
mit ihren Geld die Leisten sich Dinge
die wir uns nicht leisten können die
Leisten sich auch mal Sachen die wir uns
gar nicht leisten wollen ich bin froh
übrigens dass ich in Berlin etwas ändert
mit der CDU aber meine Hoffnung dass es
mit der SPD schnell geht und nicht ganz
ehrlich sagen ist noch nicht so
ausgeprägt und deswegen liebe Freunde
irgendwann ist die Grenze erreicht wir
wollen jetzt mal Klartext wir wollen
Klarheit haben deswegen werden wir vor
dem Sommer noch in den nächsten Wochen
die Klage gegen den
Länderfinanzausgleich einreichen
bayerisches Geld ist besser daheim
aufgehoben als in Bremen oder andersrum
zum Geld
[Applaus]
nach diesem stromchaos das hier überall
ist oder Unsicherheit kommt jetzt der
heizhammer und es ist nichts für
Folklore oder fürs schenkelklopfen ist
total ernst ich bin echt entsetzt das
obwohl die Menschen mitten schon in
einer schweren Transformation sind mit
einer Sturheit und trotzigkeit man jetzt
die Schraube immer enger zieht den
Menschen geht die finanzielle Luft zum
Atmen langsam aus
Millionen Deutsche sind verursacht
verunsichert und betroffen vor allem
Eigentümer aber viele viele ältere
Menschen die jetzigen Pläne von habe ich
für den Heizungsbereich sind völlig
überstürzt in Bayern wäre nach
Schätzungen und rund 60 Prozent der
Gebäude betroffen und die Kosten hat
jemand das der andere gesagt sollen wohl
bei 500 Milliarden Euro in Deutschland
ist dieser Plan durchdacht also man
abziehen davon dass man Holzpellet und
biogasheizungen nicht anerkennt kann mir
keiner erklären warum es vielen
Wärmepumpen es fehlen die Handwerker das
machen sollten es fehlt der Strom dafür
und die Kosten sind der Hammer nach
Schätzungen von Experten muss man wenn
man noch die ganzen sanierungsauflagen
auch aus Europa anders wurde zunimmt
muss man mit Kosten von ungefähr als
Eigentümer von dem Haus 100 bis 300.000
Euro rechnen
die Wärmepumpen allein einzubauen können
zum Teil für Geringverdiener und Leuten
mit geringerem Einkommen ungefähr so
viel sein wie sie fast im Jahr verdienen
und den Rentnern Rentner liebe
Freundinnen Freunde den gibt es da gar
keine echte Hilfe der Hinweis hey die
80-jährigen sind ausgelassen für
zunächst mal der Frage oh mist ich bin
79 was mache ich jetzt
und die Frage was passiert mit einem
80-jährigen der Mehrfamilienhaus ist
muss er trotzdem zahlen weil im Haus ist
oder wird das ganze Haus ausgelassen das
hätte zumindest den charmanteneffekt
dass die ganze Welt alle Eigentümer
suchen ob sie nicht doch einen
80-jährigen finden und von dieser
Aufgabe befreit zu werden völlig Absatz
[Applaus]
es ist liebevollen Freunde falsch
wenn der Staat in dem Fall die Ampel
ständig neue Ziele setzt immer mehr und
immer enger an der Schraube dreht jede
Normalverdiener jeden Eigentümer jeden
älteren jeden Rentner überfordert und
dann sagt es braucht einen großzügigen
Ausgleich über steuern denn die gleichen
Steuerzahler dann wieder finanzieren
wollen entweder geht der Bürger pleite
oder der Staat und deswegen sind diese
Pläne falsch abgehoben und müssen
geändert werden liebe Freunde das war
deutlich
ich verstehe nicht warum meine SPD das
mitmacht waren sie nicht mal Schutzmacht
der kleinen Leute und
die FDP zweimal zugestimmt und dann huhu
wir sind wieder dagegen wird langsam ein
bisschen peinlich
cduce haben gemeinsam beschlossen
national aufzutreten in der Frage liebe
Frau stumpf wir sagen eines diese
heizpläne müssen gestoppt werden wir
starten CDU zuerst dann wird sie nach
eine gemeinsame nationale
Unterschriftenaktion wir werden im
Bundestag im Bundesrat mit Nein stimmen
und nach der Bundestagswahl diese Pläne
wieder kippen das ist unser Versprechen
liebe Freunde das machen wir nicht mit
ich frage mich auch manchmal gibt es
einen neuen Wirtschaftsministerium in
Deutschland
scheinministerium zu gehen und ich
überlege so gerade lieber Theben und
Stoiber was Ludwig Erhard wohl gesagt
hätte wenn er so beim Fernsehen sitzt
relativ unkorrekt mit Wein Zigarette der
sah auch nicht total vegan aus wirklich
er hat und wenn er sich überlegt was das
für ein Nachfolger ist der hohe Kenntnis
im Zusammenhang mit Produktion Stopp von
Produktion soll wenn es um ihn Insolvenz
gezeigt hat gerade der Mittelstand ist
total enttäuscht gerade das Handwerk
ich finde es sowieso meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren unglaublich
wie wenig respektvoll alle reden über
die großen Industrie das ist wichtig
aber wie wenig über Mittelstand und
Handwerk in unserem Land geredet wird
das ist doch top das ist eine riesen
Leistung wir müssen Handwerk und
Mittelstand stärken und wieder mehr in
den Mittelpunkt rücken liebe Freunde und
Freunde
und weil uns Handwerk und Mittelstand
wichtig ist haben wir nicht nur ein Tag
des Handwerks in der Schule eingeführt
und dafür mehr zu werben und offen zu
sein haben wir nicht nur viel Geld jetzt
investieren Ausbau von
Berufsbildungszentren mehr als die
meisten Länder in Deutschland sondern
wir haben uns entschieden als erstes und
einziges Land in Deutschland den
Anspruch zu setzen
mastermeister sind gleich Studium ist
kostenfrei Meister auch und deswegen
machen es wir nicht irgendwann liebe
Freunde sondern wir machen es jetzt und
in diesem Jahr und zwar nicht wenn nur
jemand jetzt anfängt mit der Ausbildung
jeder der seinen Meisterbrief in diesem
Jahr bekommt kann sicher sein dass die
Meisterausbildung kostenfrei ist denn
wir stehen zum Handwerk wir stehen zu
Landwirtschaft wir stehen zur
Mittelstand wie kein anderes Bundesland
liebe Freunde
das heißt übrigens auch nicht umsonst
wir meistern das anstatt nur daran herum
zu Dottern liebe Freunde wer vermittelt
stand da ist der will auch keine Steuern
mehr sondern Steuer Entlastung wir
fordern nicht nur einen
industriestrompreis sondern die
Stromsteuer muss runter für Industrie
für Handwerk Mittelstand und Bürger die
Mehrwertsteuer muss runter und zwar für
alle Nahrungsmittel nicht nur für Gemüse
auch für Fleisch oder Fisch wir wollen
liebe Freunde keine Erhöhung der
Mehrwertsteuer für Gastronomie wir
wollen keine Erhöhung der mit der Steuer
verbeckensteuer fahren ja auch ganz
interessant dass die FDP im Bayerischen
Landtag für eine Erhöhung von Steuern
war
und man möge es mir verzeihen die FDP in
beiden ist nicht so groß aber die FDP in
Deutschland ist wichtig
finde schon krass was die machen vor der
letzten Bundestagswahl hat mir der von
mir hoch geschätzte Christian Lindner
überwiegend
hat gesagt er garantieren in eine
Bundesregierung keine Schulden dann
gemacht und eingehalten keine Steuern
wenn erhöht lasst uns sehen was die
Realität ist
dieser Bundesfinanzminister die Welt ist
schwierig Dinge ändern sich mag sein hat
aber die meisten Schulden aufgenommen
was ist Theo Waigel angegriffen worden
als er damals die deutsche Einheit
finanzieren musste als erreicht hat mit
viel viel weniger Geld das alles
sowjetischen Soldaten abgezogen sind das
war eine Leistung liebe Freunde und
Freunde das war das beeindruckende nicht
das was Christian Lindner jetzt an der
Stelle macht
fast 400 oder über 400 Milliarden
Schulden innerhalb von eineinhalb Jahren
das wird übrigens auch eine günstiger
wenn man es vermögen nimmt ja und was
machen wir
Bayern behält
unser starker Finanzminister Albert
führeracker der Vergleich zu mir einer
ist der noch weniger großzügig dafür
mehr das Geld zusammenhält aber wirklich
dafür wir machen es Gegenstück Bayern
hält die Schuldenbremse ein hat trotzdem
die höchste Investitionsquote ein solide
Haushalt trotz zweier Krisen und auch
noch weitere ey wir machen das liebe
Freunde weil wir an die nächste
Generation denken und lieber Edmund das
Erbe des ausgeglichen Haushalts bleibt
bei uns das geben wir nicht auf niemals
auf keinen Fall
es Versprechen der FDP war keine
Schulden okay und keine Steuererhöhung
was ist jetzt eigentlich letztes Jahr
passiert vor Weihnachten waren die
Notare alle ausgebucht warum weil die
FDP die Erbschaftssteuer massiv erhöht
hat und zwar nicht nur die
Bewertungsmaßstäbe für Grundstücke so
hat gleichzeitig Freibeträge nicht
angepasst das ist de facto die größte
erbschaftssteuererhöhung der jüngeren
Geschichte jetzt zeige ich euch ich
finde sowieso die Erbschaftssteuer
generell unfair weil sie schon eine
Steuer auf bereits versteuertem
Einkommen ist
aber uns belastet sie doppelt wir werden
bestraft dafür dass wir gut und
attraktiv sind warum sind die
Grundstückspreise bei uns höher weil
halt die Leute eher zu uns als woanders
hingehen ja manchmal ist es uns ja
selbst fast schon ein bisschen zu viel
wenn ich das sagen darf das Ergebnis ist
jetzt aber weil Bayern so hohe
Grundstückspreise hat müssen die
Menschen enorme Erbschaft Steuern zahlen
das führt dazu dass in vielen Teilen
Bayerns Mittelstand Familienbetriebe
aber auch Kinder nicht mehr richtig
Erben können wenn sie das Haus von
Eltern und Großeltern über Generationen
vererbt behalten und das Erbe antreten
wollen dann müssen Sie dieses Haus
verkaufen liebe Freunde am Ende droht
der ausverkaufte Heimat das können wir
nicht akzeptieren und es sind klagen wir
wir halten das zur verfassungswidrig
diese ungerechte Erbschaftssteuer muss
weg liebe Freunde sie muss geändert
werden
also der erste zentrale Punkt für uns
ist wo stand erhalten Mitte Mittelstand
stärken
gegensteuerhörungen sondern für
Entlastung das zweite große Megathema
nicht auf allen Parteitagen so geschätzt
weil es für den Einnahmen auch zu
schwierig ist ist schon das Thema
Bildung Betreuung und Forschung es geht
schon um eine Lebensqualität für unsere
ganzen Familie die Vereinbarkeit von
familienberuf die beste Bildung für
Kinder und Jugendliche und die modernste
Forschungen der Welt dabei zu sein
deswegen werden wir Schule weiter
verbessern übrigens die bayerische
Bildung ist nie perfekt lieber Charlie
Freller es gibt gar nicht dass alle
zufrieden sind Frau Fleischmann ist
heute da und obwohl wir viel machen wird
sie sicherlich noch was finden was man
noch besser machen kann keine Frage
aber es ist schon besser als anderswo im
bildungsranking liegt Bayern mit ganz
vorne mit Sachsen wir haben die
geringsten Schulabbrecher werden die
beste Digitalisierung und trotzdem
Zuwachs der Schülers unser Ziel mehr
Qualität mehr Empathie und mit digitale
in der Schule zu haben wir haben in den
letzten fünf Jahren unser Versprechen
gehalten und über 5000 Lehrer neu
eingestellt wir haben es erst einmal der
Geschichte über 100.000 Lehrerinnen
Lehrer in Bayern und für die nächsten
fünf Jahre und wir 8000 neue
stellenausschreiben wie bekommen wir das
und wie machen wir das wir gehen
übrigens nicht den Weg wie manch andere
Bundesländer die offiziell sagen wir
verzichten auf ein pädagogisches Studium
wir nehmen nur noch Quereinsteiger man
kann das mal machen aber liebe Freunde
und Freunde unsere Kinder haben
hochqualifiziertes pädagogisches
Personal verdient und das wollen wir
Ihnen als Bayern als CSU auch geben und
gewährleisten
[Applaus]
deswegen werden wir studienkapazitäten
ausbauen vor allem in Südbayern da
brauchen wir es wir haben A13 die
Einführung jetzt für Grund- und
Mittelschullehrer beschlossen seine
bessere Bezahlung übrigens A13 lohnt
sich in Bayern besonders zum Vergleich
A13 bedeutet nicht überall in
Deutschland A13 Albert Bürger hat es
einmal ausgerechnet beamtenminister ab
13 in Bayern bedeutet im Jahr 4000 Euro
mehr als in Nordrhein-Westfalen 7000
mehr als in Hessen liebe Freunde und
Freunde das lässt sich schon sehen und
noch unterstützt mit regionalprämien für
unterversorgte Regionen bei der
Ausstattung der Digitalisierung
insbesondere Tablets für alle Schüler
bis 2028 wollen wir die beste Bildung
für unsere Kinder erhalten
was machen eigentlich die anderen zum
Thema Bildungspolitik
ich habe fast nichts gehört und nichts
gelesen doch nur ein Smartphone der
wichtigste bildliche Ansatz der
bayerischen FDP war Schulbeginn künftig
um 9 Uhr
liebe FDP in Bayern
ich verstehe dass euch schwerfällt früh
aufzustehen ja aber meinen kleinen Tipp
wer es so zu spät kommt den bestraft am
Ende der Wählern das mit Recht liebe
Freundin
neben Ausbau der Schule Liebe Ulli
scharf ist uns Betreuung ganz wichtig in
Kita und in der Grundschule auch hier
geht es um die Vereinbarkeit von Familie
und Beruf wir haben von 18 bis 22 Dank
auch der großen umsetzungsleistung der
Kommunen lieber Markus Panama als
städtetagspräsident und lieber Thomas
Kammer sind als landkreispräsident
Christian bannreiter hat der
eine noch schönere Aufgabe bekommen
hoffe ich dass du siehst
wir haben dann den letzten fünf Jahren
Kita und Hortplätze
82.000 neu ausgegeben
wir wollen aufgrund der Entwicklung der
Kinder in den nächsten fünf Jahren
mindestens 50.000 neu dazu bringen und
wenn man dann noch sieht dass die
Betreuung während der Ganztag
Ganztagsbetreuung wäre in der
Grundschule ein großes
Gemeinschaftsprojekt von bundländern
Kommunen noch mal 120.000 Plätze sein
sollen dann wären es rund 180.000 neue
Plätze in Bayern das wird schon ein
dickes Ding ist zustimmen das kostet
viel Geld und vor allem muss man noch
eine Menge tun um Erzieherinnen Erzieher
Kinderpfleger und Kinderpfleger dabei
besser zu stellen
dass man in Bayern übrigens
Familienpolitik und Kinderpolitik besser
machen kann das kann man einer Leistung
sehen die es nur bei uns gibt wir bauen
nicht nur Plätze natürlich wir haben
unsere Familien besonders unterstützt
wir haben das bayerische Familiengeld
das wird in all den Leistungsbilanzen
gerne verschwiegen es ärgert die anderen
unter einer des Minister muss man es
erwähnen ich sag ja in Bayern gibt's
Familiengeld nur
im Familiengeld
bis solo 12.000 Euro pro Kind wenn man
mehr Kinder hat bei drei Kindern bis zu
40.000 das hilft übrigens im Moment
enorm gegen die Inflation wird es mal
mit Wohngeld vergleicht das
einkommensabhängig ist bei uns bekommen
das alle diese Unterstützung seit 2018
dreieinhalb Milliarden Euro
800.000 Kinder haben davon profitiert
das ist Familienpolitik das ist
Sozialpolitik und die gibt es nur in
Bayern liebe Freunde und sonst nirgendwo
in ganz Deutschland
noch zur Schule
wir haben auch das Ziel neben der
geistigen Bewegung zu stärken auf die
körperliche mir macht es sorgen liebe
Freunde und ich habe mal einen
Rettungsschwimmerschein sogar gemacht
ich bin heute noch perfekt könnte weiß
ich nicht aber vor ein paar Jahren ging
es noch
mir macht es Sorge dass immer weniger
Kinder schwimmen können es kann so nicht
sein in einem Land wie Bayern und
deswegen müssen wir mehr tun alle Kinder
sollen die Chance haben schwimmen lernen
zu können und nicht nur irgendwelchen
aufgestellten Containern wie es irgendwo
in Deutschland jetzt angeboten wird
deswegen ich weiß Albert dass uns das
gemeinsam schwer fällt aber das machen
wir wir müssen die bisherigen Schulen
Schwimmbäder Programme deutlich
erweitern liebe Freunde es wird Sonne
reichen mit dem derzeitigen Programm
[Applaus]
und wir müssen auch ein deutlich
besseres Anreiz geben Schwimmlehrer zu
werden so noch ein letzter Inhalt zur
Bildungspolitik
ich wundere mich manchmal was ist da für
vorschläger aus Deutschland gibt ich
will nur eins sagen wir wollen die
Qualität der bayerischen Bildung oben
halten nicht absteigen wir wollen keine
einheitslehrer keine Einheitsschule kein
einheitsabi und wir sind gegen eine
Berliner bildungszentralismus und wenn
schon in Deutschland nur noch ein Abi
gelten soll dann können die anderen gern
das bayerische machen liebe Freunde wir
stellen die Aufgaben gerne zur Verfügung
[Applaus]
zur Bildung gehört auch fassen
Zukunft ich habe in meinem Leben
[Musik]
wirklich drei mega Herausforderungen zu
schultern gehabt oder Projekte auf den
Weg gebracht in vielen anderen das eine
war damals die Rettung der Landesbank wo
ich viel geschwitzt habe und wo wir
heute lieber Albert zusammen wieder
Gewinn machen das war die Rettung
Bayerns vor dieser unglaublichen
corona-ausforderung und das ist jetzt
die hightech-agenda das was Strauß und
Goppel in den 70ern Edmund Stoiber den
90er gemacht haben das tun wir jetzt
auch wir stellen Weichen für die Zukunft
auch wenn im Moment es nicht jeder sieht
ist es die langfristig wichtigste
Lebensversicherung Markus Blum hat
letzte in einer beeindruckenden
Regierungserklärung noch mal deutlich
gemacht das Gesamtprojekt sind jetzt
fünf Milliarden Euro bis 2025 das ist
die größte forschungsoffensive
liebevollen Freunde die Bayern je hatte
und die ein Bundesland gemacht hat wir
machen für künstliche Intelligenz mehr
als Italien Spanien wir sind beim
Supercomputing auf dem Level von
Südkorea
wir bauen das größte Zentrum für
Biomedizin in Martinsried zusammen mit
der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft für 600
Millionen Euro und ja auch Luft und
raumfahrtboomt die neue Fakultät der TUM
ist bald die größte in Europa
Verdoppelung des Studenten jedes Jahr
die hyperloop-teststrecke kommt und 50%
der Aufträge der ESA das ist die
europäische NASA geh nach Bayern weil
wir tolle Unternehmen haben und ja es
sieht gut aus dass ein
mondkontrollzentrum denn es gibt neue
Missionen der ESA dahin dass ein
mondkontrollzentrum
schließt sich der Kreis von vor fünf
Jahren dass ein mondkontrollzentrum in
Bayern möglich ist und wir werden es
auch unterstützen liebe Freunde Bayern
ist das Space Valley von Deutschland
[Applaus]
Hobby ja nicht
liebe Freunde ihr müsst mal sehen bei
highter könnt ihr kennen was da für eine
Begeisterung in der steht für ein Spirit
oder wie wir Franken sagen was für ein
Floh ja
ich kann euch berichten von leuchtenden
Augen von Studenten und Professoren wenn
wir in Schweinfurt einen neuen
Studiengang von Robotik auf den Weg
bringen wenn ihr den Semesterstart der
TH Augsburg miterlebt hättet das war mir
ein Happing wie in einem Robinson Club
statt ein Vorlesungsbeginn wie ich ihn
erlebt habe und bei der TU München waren
wir auch zu Semester war das Knistern
der Zukunft spürbar die hyperloop-truppe
eine so coole junge Gemeinschaft liebe
Freunde und Freunde die sich da auf den
Weg bringt da ist so viel Optimismus so
viel zukunftsoffenheit dahinter das
werdet ihr auf keinen grünen Parteitag
vergleichbar finden liebe Freunde ja
mir sind Nazi lieber als Nagler wir
brauchen Bayern die anpacken und nicht
solche die nur verweigern und Luft und
Raumfahrt ist zum Beispiel eine der
vielen Chancen das hat übrigens als
erster und ich habe mal nachgelesen er
hat auch keinen Lob dafür bekommen
damals das hat als erster Franz-Josef
Strauß in den 70er Jahren gemacht und
das was Strauß gemacht hat was Steuer
gemacht hat das machen wir jetzt auch
das ist CSU Genialität das ist CSU
Tradition über Generationen hinweg
und übrigens das ist Wirtschaftspolitik
wir sind ein Land das keine Rohstoffe
hat gibt zwar Gas im Norden bei uns aber
nicht
wir sind kein Billiglohn Land und wollen
seine bleiben das was wir haben ist
unser Hirn das wir sie können es
Hightech und Forschung und mit unserem
Ökosystem an Forschung dass wir jetzt
überall in Bayern entwickeln kommen neue
Firmen bleiben alte Firmen oder
vergrößern erweitern sich einige
Beispiele der letzten Jahre was wir
gemeinsam auch unterstützt haben bMW
will ein neues Werk für E-Mobilität in
niederbayernbahn der Siemens Campus in
Erlangen eine riesige Investition für
Forschung Technologie die Firmen rasch
und Sanders investieren in Penzberg und
Holzkirchen Dank und zur Unterstützung
Bosch Bamberg bekommt Unterstützung
bleibt im Spiel gerade im Bereich
Wasserstoff immer in Nürnberg liebe
Freunde und Freunde wird eine Batterie
entwickeln Batterie für e-trucks dank
unserer Forschung Premium Erotik in
Augsburg bleibt der gemeinsamen Bemühung
vor wenigen Tagen wurde verkündet dass
ein neues chip-forschungszentrum in
Nürnberg wahrscheinlich in der Region
Nürnberg von ZF und nehmen Google und
Microsoft liebe Freunde kommt Apple mit
2000 Mitarbeiter zu uns und sorry wenn
ich das sage wir müssen keine Milliarden
Subventionen geben wir investieren nur
in Forschung liebe Freundinnen Freunde
ist diesmal andere sind arm und sexy wir
sind wohlhabend und sexy und klug und
deswegen kommt man zu uns und nirgendwo
anders kommen die Menschen
[Applaus]
es wird da einander gesagt haben nein
habe ich jetzt viel Großstädte gehört
Hightech ist kein Privileg der
Ballungszentren
du musst im ländlichen Raum da sein
insbesondere Technologietransfer
deswegen haben wir schon in der letzten
Monaten die technologietransferzentren
von 31 auf 46 aufgestockt und unser Ziel
ist in der nächsten Legislaturperiode in
jedem Regierungsbezirk aber vor allem in
jedem Landkreis in jedem Landkreis muss
ein neues TCZ kommen nur bayern macht es
so wir wollen Hightech nicht nur im
Ballungszentrum sondern auch und gerade
im ländlichen Raum liebe Freunde
Stichwort ländlicher Raum
viele sagen wir müssen an die Mobilität
ausweiten ja deswegen lieber Christian
bambreiter hast du einen ÖPNV hohes
Haushalt vorgelegt der so hoch wie nie
ist an der Bundesländer streichen
übrigens wir erhöhen nicht nur die
Tickets liebe Freundinnen Freunde 49
Euro 29 Euro für Azubis Studenten ein
Euro für das Mitnehmen von Fahrrädern
der Ausbau von
klima-gesetz lieber Thomas Kreuzer die
Fraktion ist auf den Weg gebracht wird
kommen mit dem Ausbau der Radwege aber
ich sage euch eines
Lastenrad allein
und U-Bahn wird für Teile des ländliche
Raumes eine Zeit brauchen bis sie die
Ersatz Alternative sind die Leute werden
das Auto brauchen und deswegen sage ich
es hier auch sehr deutlich mittlerweile
ducken sicher entweder einige weg wenn
es ums Auto geht oder eine zeigen offen
ihre feindliche autofratze die Grünen
sind keine Fans fürs Auto wir sagen ja
zum Auto wir sagen ja zum Straßenbau und
nochmal die Adresse des Bundes auch die
A94 und die A3 müssen weiter und
ausgebaut werden liebe Freunde sonst
reicht's nicht
wir sagen auch ja zum synthetischen
Verbrenner wir könnten uns noch mehr
vorstellen wir sagen ja zu ihr a in
München das tun sich die Grünen im
Stadtrat extrem schwer das nur halbwegs
zu begrüßen lieber Georg Albrecht du
weißt wie das da ist wir sagen überall
ja und ich bleibe auch dabei in keinem
Land der Welt
wird sein wichtigstes Wirtschaftsgut so
doof und schlecht behandelt wie bei uns
in keinem Land der Welt wird der
wichtigste Wirtschaftsfaktor ständig
klein und schlecht geredet wir tun es
nicht wir sind die einzige Partei die
sich zum Auto bekennt Bayern ist
Autoland und CSU bleibt auch autoparteil
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
[Applaus]
zum ländlichen Raum gehört nicht nur
Mobilität logischerweise sondern auch
die Landwirtschaft wir legen ein
Bekenntnis aber auch im
Grundsatzprogramm aber im Handeln zu
bäuerlicher Kultur zu unseren
Familienbetrieben und zur Regionalität
hat auch wenn wir die meisten Bio-Bauern
in Bayern haben für mich ist es egal ob
Bio oder konventionell Hauptsache
regional Hauptsache Bayern
ich sage euch eines der
bauernverbandspräsident Felsen ist heute
da
es buen ja im Moment alle um die
Landwirtschaft ja aber sind wir jetzt
ehrlich wer reisten eigentlich wirklich
was die FDP in Berlin hat total
Enttäuschung die AFD völlig sinnlos die
Freien Wähler sind sicherlich dafür aber
ohne Einfluss und die Grünen Feinde der
bäuerlichen Lebenskultur wir handeln für
unsere bäuerlichen Familien wir haben
die höchste Förderung je in den letzten
fünf Jahren dass man das mal gehört hat
haben wir 9 Milliarden Euro investiert
in die landwirtschaftliche Förderung ein
Plus im Vergleich zu 2018 übrigens um 30
Prozent wir fühlen unsere Kantinen 50%
Regionalität ein wir haben den Wunsch
der Landfrauen aufgenommen die
Alltagskompetenz in die Schule zu
integrieren
wir werden ich finde es übrigens ein
wichtiges Projekt dabei ja
wobei wir noch Frau Fleischmann da sieht
man aber drüber also wir müssen einmal
gucken dass das dann auch umgesetzt wird
weil ihr habt von einigen gelesen dass
es die eine andere Lehrkraft gibt die
verlangt dann an den pausenprotec um zu
sagen ob das Pausenbrote Schülers a des
Schülers B a von Anton und Berta wo die
Kinder heißen natürlich anders ja
Andromeda und Benedikt keine Ahnung ja
dann wird gesagt dein Essen ist aber
klimaschädlicher also liebe Freunde und
Freunde so geht es dann am Ende nicht
das Alltagskompetenz heißt grüne Politik
zu machen es geht natürlich nicht ja
[Applaus]
wir leisten für die Dinge Verordnung
haben wir gut miteinander geredet Hilfe
es wird neue Messstellen geben es liegt
im Verantwortungsbereich der Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Freien Wähler wir
entwickeln Herr der Fälle um den
Betrieben zu helfen und wir werden die
Forschung für eine moderne Düngung
voranbringen Liebe Michaela danke dir
übrigens auch mal bei dir für dein ganz
großen Einsatz in der Landwirtschaft es
ist nicht immer leicht wir wissen es
sehr zu schätzen
vorbei
gibt kaum ein Thema dass sie umstritten
ist wie Landwirtschaft sind wir ehrlich
es gibt doch ein Kulturkampf um Land und
Landwirtschaft
allen wollen alles sagen wir müssen der
Welt beim Essen helfen warum können wir
denn nicht eigentlich das leisten was
wir leisten könnten wir könnten viele
Menschen vor dem Hungertod retten wenn
wir in Deutschland das produzieren
könnten was für ein möglich wäre ich
finde das geradezu absurd und danke der
EVP lieber Manfred vor wenigen Tagen ein
gemeinsamer Beschluss dies wieder zu
ändern Deutschland ist ja an der Stelle
besonders negativ auffallen ihr habt ja
mal Möglichkeiten geschaffen dieses
Flächen stilllegen liebe Freunde
diese Manni das bei uns wertvollste
Flächen stillgelegt dem Eigentum der
Nahrungsmittelproduktion entzogen werden
ist aus meiner Sicht der falsche Weg
Flächenstilllegung und Ausgleichsflächen
führen in die Irre wir können übrigens
den Flächenverbrauch reduzieren indem
wir weniger Stilllegungen haben lass die
Landwirte einfach ihre Arbeit machen
liebe Freunde
dann brauchen wir ein Bekenntnis zur
Tierhaltung auch da wird ein Kampf gegen
Tier- und Fleisch geführt ich bleibe
dabei jeder soll essen was er will man
sieht ja auch jedem an so ja die
einsetzen mir auf Gemüse die anderen
mehr Fleisch und es gibt auch sicher
einige Lokale die jetzt tatsächlich
Insekten anbieten wegen mir
aber ich habe letztens eine Sendung
gesehen da ist es ein Prozent sind
Veganer in Deutschland 7% Vegetarier
super aber ich frage mich bei 1% Veganer
warum man krampfhaft versucht 99%
umzuziehen oder ihnen ständig ein
schlechtes Gewissen einzureden liebe
Freunde das
Münchner würde und Gastronomen haben wir
bei der Münchner Frühlingsfest gesagt
dass sie sich gegen die Forderung einer
kompletten bio-wiesen der Grünen werden
und warum
weil nach einem Tag so war der ein
Aussagen nach einem Tag wohl alle
biohendl in Bayern verfuttert werden
liebe Freunde der Ersatz wäre dann
wahrscheinlich nur noch Tofu Weißwürste
wer glaubt dass man mit Tofu Weißwürsten
die Wiesen auf dem Besucherrekord halten
kann eine sagen dann wäre die Wiesen in
fünf Jahren auf dem schönen aber
niedrigen Niveau der schnepfenreiter
kirchweil liebe Freunde das machen wir
nicht mit lass die Leute essen was sie
wollen und lasst es Oktoberfest und die
Wiesen feiern wie sie es wollen
und da wird noch über das Fleisch
gekämpft da kommt schon die nächste
super Idee und man stellt sich ja die
Frage angesichts der Probleme der Welt
ob das ernsthafte Probleme sind jetzt
heißt es Zucker ist total schlimm ja
Fett ist auch schlimm Eiweiß ist schlimm
wobei ich mir dann irgendwie Frage kein
Zucker kein Eiweiß kein Fett
lang geht's dann fallen nicht gut gell
so aber gut jetzt soll also ein Verbot
kommen von Süßigkeiten Werbung mit der
Begründung wir müssen die Kinder
schützen vor Süßigkeiten
meine Grundsatzfrage
was Kinder essen der entscheidet es
eigentlich
wieso muss das Funktionäre entscheiden
warum dürfen die Eltern nicht den erster
Linie entscheiden was Kinder essen
sollen wir wollen da das Elternrecht an
erster Stelle und nicht irgendwelche
verhungerten grünen Funktionäre die den
Eltern einreden was Sie essen was Sie
bestellen und was sie den Kindern kaufen
dürfen liebe Freunde
und gestern Abend war die heute-show
freue mich immer jedes Mal wenn sie uns
interessiert beobachten
gestern wieder gegen Wolf oder Bären
und natürlich ist es dadurch ganz lustig
gemacht gewesen war eine der stärkeren
Sendungen aber
haben die Leute eigentlich so ein
bisschen verstanden was da eigentlich in
ländlich Räumen stattfindet
ich glaube im Landfrauentag in
Garmisch-Partenkirchen Mittenwald da
weint eine Dame eine Landfrau nicht nur
weil die gerissen wurde sondern weil es
mitten vor dem Hof mitten vor dem Haus
ist wo sie wohnt
die Menschen haben Sorge
und ich habe jetzt wirklich nichts gegen
den Wolf und gegen den Berg aber bitte
verstehen wir doch einfach mal das sind
Raubtiere und die gehören nicht zu uns
lebe Freunde und Freunde was denn sonst
und weil Gefahr für Mensch aber vor
allem für Nutztiere für die Weidehaltung
droht und ja das gilt übrigens nicht nur
beim Wolf auch der hochwertigste Fisch
der Welt der fränkischen Oberpfälzer
kaufen ja
kann ich jedem nur empfehlen mal zu
essen der wird ausgefuttert von Ottern
jetzt sind Otter toll aber wir müssen
doch irgendwo eine Balance halten und
deswegen haben wir entschieden ich habe
die Anweisung gegeben in dankbar dass
alle mitgemacht haben eine neue
Verordnung zu machen Entnahme leichter
zu ermöglichen denn für uns steht der
Schutz des Menschen der Schutz der
Landwirtschaft und der heilt unser
ländlichen Kulturräume an erster Stelle
liebe Freunde dazu stehen wir auch
zum ländlichen
Mobilität neben Landwirtschaft auch das
Thema Gesundheit ganz besonders wenn in
Bayern eine sehr gute
Gesundheitsversorgung fast noch besser
in den Städten
wir wollen auf Dauer Gesundheit für alle
und überall erhalten lieber Klaus
holitschek wir machen was wir können wir
bilden mehr Ärzte aus unser
landarztprogramm noch von Melanie Hummel
auf den Weg gebrängt trägt Früchte
landarztprogramm landarztprämie über
tausend in den letzten Jahren
hebammenprogramm nur in Bayern übrigens
und mich schwierige Situation in der
Geburtshilfe zu stärken wir machen
Markus Blume neue Studienplätze bei den
neu zugelegten liegen wir an erster
Stelle in Augsburg in Oberfranken jetzt
auch in Niederbayern bei Medizin Campus
und wir haben die höchste Investition
pro Kopf in den Krankenhausbau in
Deutschland liebe Freunde und Freunde in
den letzten Jahren den letzten fünf
Jahren über drei Milliarden das wird
auch nicht das Ende sein wir werden noch
mehr machen warum weil Krankenhaus im
ländlichen Raum ist existenziell für die
Zukunft der Menschen
und und werden wir ein extra Programm
machen und die kleinen Häuser im
Transformationsprozess zu unterstützen
mit 100 Millionen für nächsten Jahre wo
wir geburtstagsstationen erhalten und
die Notfallversorgung lieber Klaus
bewusst ausfahren wollen kommt da
Lauterbach mit neuen Plänen
die Pläne von ein Lauterbach zur
krankenhausreform sind nicht nur
verfassungswidrig sie sind auch grob
falsch lebe Freundin Freunde es kann dir
die Zukunft sein sage ich ein Beispiel
zu glauben dass Berlin weiß wo ein
Krankenhaus stehen soll ich kann mich
erinnern ich war bei der 50 Jahrfeier in
freier und Grafenau dabei 50 Jahre
Landkreis Gefahren ein toller Termin bei
Sebastian Gruber und da gab es hinterher
so ein Gespräch
über die beginne damals und wie das war
bei der Gemeindegebietsreform und dann
sagte einer der Mitstreiter damals sagte
na ja zum Thema Zusammenarbeit und daher
kommt übrigens auch manche
krankenhausstruktur in Bayern sagt er na
ja
für uns damals in Freyung war klar ne
evangelische heiraten
und der schwersten Schmerzen aber eine
aus Grafenau ist völlig und denkbar
so war das damals und so haben wir heute
auch kleinere Strukturen aber zu glauben
dass man doch alles weg streichen kann
den Nürnberger lieber Sebastian sagen
sie müssen automatisch ins
förderklinikum ja
oder den fördern bei uns ja das ist
einfach absurd und die Gefahr besteht
darin dass am Ende kleine Standorte hops
gehen der ländliche Raum negativ wird
und anstatt sich darum zu kümmern dass
es mehr Antibiotika mehr sieberfestsäfte
gibt der Bund macht da nichts nur bayern
macht was danke Klaus Holidaycheck für
deinen tollen Einsatz wir haben wegen
dir wieder mehr und bessere Versorgung
[Applaus]
statt die Aufgaben zu lösen
berauschen sich Lauterbach und Ärzte mir
an neuen drogenplänen aber fragt bei
dieser Ampel immer haben die nichts
anderes zu tun
sie entwickeln totale Aktivität bei
unwichtigen schädlichen
und sie tun nichts bei dem was relevant
ist habt ihr es gelesen
90 Joints pro Monat soll jetzt das Ziel
sein 90
natürlich hat das Grün rote München
sofort Georg gesagt ja wir wollen auch
Drogen Region werden
wir werden so weit wie es irgendwie
können das nicht erlauben wir wollen
keine Drogen für Kinder und Jugendliche
in Bayern liebe Freunde was soll denn
das
statt Drogen wollen wir lieber die
Pflege ausbauen für Bayern ist das
wichtig es geht hier um Respekt und
Würde ich habe das gestern auch beim VdK
gesagt von 18 bis 22 in den letzten
Jahren haben wir fast 4000 Plätze
gefördert und werden von 23 bis 28 8000
ins Visier nehmen um bis zu unterstützen
wir fördern auch die Pflege daheim das
hat uns die leider viel zu früh
verstorbene und ich glaube wir alle
vermissen Sie unsere Barbara stammen
immer ans Herz gelegt vergesst mir die
pflegenden Angehörigen nicht nur bei uns
gibt es für derzeit über 400.000
Menschen ein Pflegegeld von 1000 € ab
der Pflegestufe 2 und ich sagte deswegen
wir blicken nicht nur ins All sondern
auch tief ins Herz der Menschen
wir mit Liebe daheim pflegt der soll die
Anerkennung finden und liebevollen
Freund ich sag's mal so der eine andere
fragt immer wenn man nachts um drei
geweckt würde weil ich kann nicht weiß
wie die stattfinden soll wie auch im
hermann hat mal angeboten diesen
Messenger Warndienst diesen
katastrophendienst mehr einzuführen aber
wenn ein CSU-Mitglied nachts um drei
geweckt werden sollte ich glaube ich
werde sogar wach dann weiß er das ist
drei Leistungen gibt die ist in keinem
anderen Bundesland gibt wir sind es
einzige und
erste und im Moment auch letzte
Bundesland in dem es ein Familiengeld in
dem es ein Pflegegeld und eine
kostenfreie Meisterausbildung gibt das
ist nur Bayern liebe Freunde das ist nur
die CSU
und weil wir heute auch das
Grundsatzprogramm beschließen und über
das Thema aussprechen
Respekt und Würde fußen auf den
christlichen Menschenbild
wir sind übrigens die einzige Parteien
Bayern die sich zu den Zeh noch offen
bekennt manchmal sogar mehr als die
hauptamtlichen die für das C stehen
würden liebe Freunde
in der Ampel lieber Alexander denk mal
nach Paragraph 218 zu streichen und den
assistierten Suizid vorzubereiten ich
sage euch die Position es gibt Dinge für
die sind wir und es gibt Dinge das sind
wir klar dagegen für uns ist das Schutz
des ungeborenen Lebens weiter wichtig
wir setzen uns ein für Menschen mit
Handicap und wir wollen palliativ und
hospizmedizin statt assistierten Suizid
des C ist bei uns keine Frage des
Buchstabens oder Traditionen das C steht
für uns für eine Haltung und wir sagen
Ja zum Leben und ja zum Schutz des
Lebens liebe Freunde
und wenn wir schon vom Herzen reden dann
will ich sagen wie herzlich wir als
Bayern Menschen aufgenommen haben Bayern
hilft tut es gerne und das Überzeugung
wir haben mehr Menschen aus der Ukraine
aufgenommenes Frankreich
ich danke allen die mitgeholfen und
natürlich sofort das den Kommunen aber
lasst uns bitte auch die vielen vielen
Ehrenamtlichen erwähnen die seit über
einem Jahr unglaubliches leisten
Menschen eine neue Hoffnung und neue
Zukunft zu gehen wirklich herzliches
Dankeschön dafür
auch wenn wir auch im Hermann uns immer
sehr kaum mehr Menschen aus der Ukraine
kommen weil die Ukraine der übrigens
einen tapferen Kampf führt und ich bin
übrigens bis heute chem ich mich für
manchen deutschen Intellektuellen ganz
großen Schlaumeier der in den Talkshows
der Republik sich nach wenigen Tagen
hingestellt und sagt das verlieren die
Ehe die sollen am besten gleich aufgeben
eine solche Respektlosigkeit habe ich
noch nie erlebt wir stehen zur Ukraine
liebe Freunde und sagen Danke für den
mutigen und tapferen Kampf den sie dort
leisten
aber auch wenn immer weniger Menschen
aus der Ukraine kommen dafür viele
andere Menschen nach Deutschland
der Bund droht leider das ganze Land und
fahren die Kommunen zu überfordern
wir lesen dieser Tage das ist nächste
Woche einen Gipfel geben wird eine
ministerpräsenkonferenz die haben wir
mit Olaf Scholz deswegen gemacht um
endlich eine vernünftige tragfähige
gemeinsame Lösung zu finden für die
Herausforderung der Migration wir lesen
gerade dass es da nichts geben soll wir
hören übrigens sogar dass der Bund
überlegt dass die Länder noch mehr
zahlen wollen Joachim Herrmann ist dabei
ausgeflippt als er das gehört hat und
wenn Joachim Herrmann ausflippt liebe
Freunde dann muss es was Ernsthaftes
sein anders kann ich nicht sagen ja
wir wollen helfen wir sagen ja zu Hilfe
aber wir sagen nein zu Überforderung
liebe Freundinnen Freunde wir können
nicht alles schaffen die Länder Zahlen
im Moment 16 Milliarden Mitteln Kommunen
zusammen für die Unterbringung der Bund
glaube ich 2,75 wir sagen eines es
braucht mehr Geld es braucht bessere
Unterbringung und es braucht auch keine
deutschen Alleingänge bei der Aufnahme
wenn die Ampel die Kommunen am
ausgestreckten Arm verhungern ist dann
Spalte das das Land die andere Spalte
Deutschland und das wollen wir nicht das
lassen wir nicht zu
natürlich braucht es Arbeitsmigration
das sind wir dafür wir haben eigene
Büros jetzt eingerichtet in Albanien
richten Sie einen bosnien-herzog wieder
in den Belgrad und wir haben auch
gemeinsam entschieden das wäre bei uns
arbeitet oder ein Ausbildungsplatz hat
bei uns bleiben kann aber umgekehrt muss
eines auch ganz klar Geld liebe Freunde
Straftäter müssen das Land verlassen
dazu gibt es überhaupt keine Alternative
und der Bund muss
illegale Zuwanderung stoppen ja man
Vorschlag wird es geht vor fünf Jahren
hat Joachim Herrmann wir haben gemeinsam
die bayerische Grenzpolizei eingerichtet
was war das für ein Theater bringt
nichts falsch schlimm Polizei Staat bla
bla bla bla
nach fünf Jahren Bilanz Joachim in fünf
Jahren 80.000 fahndungstreffer 80.000
Menschenhändler mit Menschenschmuggler
Waffenschieber Autohändler alle Formen
von Verbrechen gefunden wir haben damit
Bayern und Deutschland sicherer gemacht
und eines kann ich euch sagen wenn
uns darauf dass am Ende auch für
Deutschland eine Grenzpolizei überall um
das Land sicherer zu machen so wie
Bayern ist Vorbild an der Stelle
und lieber Joachim ich danke Dir ganz
persönlich du bist nicht nur der
Sicherheitsminister und ich finde der
beste Innenminister in Deutschland
[Applaus]
du bist auch ein super
Integrationsminister
liebe Freundin Freunde Bayern ist
integrationsland Nummer eins wir haben
die meiste zuwanderungs müssen die
meisten gar nicht die meiste Zuwanderung
und trotzdem die niedrigste Arbeitslosen
und Kriminalitätsrate bei uns
funktioniert es wir haben auch
wahnsinnig viele Einbürgerungen und
übrigens von ganz ganz tollen Bayern die
sich diese Einbürgerung und es
Bekenntnis zur Staatsbürgerschaft hatte
arbeitet haben eine Staatsbürgerschaft
wird übrigens nicht verschenkt oder
verlost
eine Staatsbürgerschaft ist das höchste
Recht eine Staates nicht irgendwie so
eine Clubkarte oder
Vereinsmitgliedschaft eine
Staatsbürgerschaft
erfordert Bekenntnis zur Werten und
Sprache ohne Sprache gibt es keine
Integration und die Ampel will jetzt
darauf verzichten wir sagen aber wer
deutsche oder Deutscher werden will der
muss Deutsch oder zumindest beide
sprechen können liebe Freunde das ist
doch unverzichtbar für Integration
und als letzten Punkt vielleicht den
emotionalsten für manche auch für uns
wir stehen zum bayerischen Lebensgefühl
zu Freiheit Gemütlichkeit Liberalität
die Liberalitas Bavaria ist unser
Lebensmotto wir lehnen diese
umerziehungsphantasien von der Ampel und
ihrer vorfeldaktivistin allen NGOs ab
weiß blau klingt gut besser als rot grün
gelb bliebe vor einem Freunde diese
Aktivisten diese Gruppen diese Vorfeld
Denker die wollen ein anderes
Deutschland die wollen ein anderes
Bayern aber ich nicht wir nicht wir
wollen Bayern erhalten wirst ist liebe
Freunde und Freunde nichts anderes
jeder kann reden was er will eine Stunde
im Bayerischen Landtag belegt die
Vielfalt an doch sehr spannenden
argumentationsmustern
aber eine zwanghafte Sprache die lehnen
wir ab zwanghaftes schindern oder vor
einigen Wochen gab es ein Vorschlag aus
der Tagesschau Online-Redaktion der
Tagesschau
man wolle künftig das Wort Mutter
streichen
und das Setzen durch zu Gebärende Person
es war nicht ganz klar was die Männer
sind Zulieferbetrieb ich weiß es nicht
ganz ja
als wäre demonstriert haben hieß es ja
man wolle des bewusst machen um
niemanden mehr zu diskriminieren liebe
Freunde das heißt diese Leute glauben
dass das Wort Mama oder Mutter ein
diskriminierendes Wahrzeichen
allen Müttern sei mal an der Stelle so
heimlich erzählt nahezu jeder Vater
versucht mit allen möglichen Tricks aber
ohne völlig Erfolg das erste Wort Papa
den Kindern irgendwie absolut ja
bleibt aber Mutter oder Mama
ehrlich Mutter oder Mama ist doch
Abstand das schönste Wort der Welt oder
gibt es ein wichtiger das war doch der
Welt
wer so denkt der hat kein Herz und es
nicht von dieser Welt das geht ja weiter
mit völlig übertreten Themen der
Identitätspolitik das Thema Indianer hat
man ja letztes Jahr ja Bäcker werden
angegriffen weil es Indianer vom Krapfen
haben dabei bleibt er da gar nicht lange
ja
letztlich glaube ich auf der
Bundesgartenschau war eine eine
Rentnergruppe eine ehrenamtliche die
sind als Mexikaner aufgetreten mit
Sombreros
riesen Debatte übrigens die Mexikaner
fanden es super wenn jemand ihre
Sombreros kauft sondern in Bayern
über was reden wir in unserem Land
eigentlich da gibt's Kriege da gibt's
Hungersnöte Liebe von Leute da finden
der Klimawandel statt und ein Teil der
politischen Klasse redet so einen Unsinn
und scharf scheiß das kann doch nicht
der Ernst von Verantwortung kompetent
sein oder
ich bin
ich bin gespannt wann auch bald die
Tracht diskutiert wird und wenn
Daniel Günther zu uns aufs Oktoberfest
kommt und eine Tracht anzieht ja und sie
auch bezahlt dann freue ich mich doch
darüber liebe Freunde David auch kein
Problem denn auch wir stehen zu dem was
unsere Kultur ist Tracht Blaskapelle
Gebirgsschützen sind mit das Beste was
Bayern zu bieten hat liebe Freundinnen
Freunde sie gehören zu uns und es ist
mir eine ganz große Ehre die Welt und
morgen wieder
Patronatstag der Gebirgsschützen dabei
zu sein und wir haben im letzten Jahr
solche Erlebnisse gehabt wo man merkt
wie auch die Menschen in der Welt damit
Bayern lieben beim Requiem für Papst
Benedikt einige waren ja dabei die
beeindruckend war das am Petersplatz in
Rom die Trachten zu sehen
was für ein Gänsehaut Moment als dann
die bayerische
Hymne die Bayernhymne das bayernlieb
gesungen wurde und wie seltsam war der
Blick von Olaf Scholz der vor mir stand
also das gehört hat ja
bei G7 bei Sicherheitskonferenz jeder
wartet es wenn er zu uns kommt ich weiß
in Berlin würde man wahrscheinlich fünf
Raver drei graffiti-sprecher
als gestern
bei uns ist es anders wisst ihr was
wie schräg die Welt manchmal ist
als damals nach dem g7-gipfel wir
empfangen haben weil sie den beiden und
all die anderen die einen haben sich
darüber unterhalten ob ihr
zertrachtenjanker richtig ist und ob der
toll oder besser ist ein wichtiger
Diskussion
und anderen die Frage gestellt
jetzt glaube die ganze Welt dass alle
deutschen so aus in Bayern
es gab eine ernsthafte Debatte in Tatzen
anderen Zeitungen
und ich wurde mir wurde die Frage
gestellt
sagen sie dazu dass jetzt die ganze Welt
denken kann dass alle Deutschen die
Bayern werden meine Antwort was für ein
riesen Imagegewinn für Deutschland liebe
Freunde wenn die Welt klappt das alles
so sind wie wir
wir sind eine mitmachen Partei die
Grünen sind eine mies macht Partei liebe
Freunde
die Landesleitung hat ganz zufällig kam
der Zettel mehr auf den Tisch mal die
Verbote der letzten Jahre
zusammengeschrieben und es werden jetzt
ungefähr noch mal eine halbe Stunde aber
ich lese nur einige vor was die Grünen
den letzten Jahren ob im Bund oder
Ländern gefördert haben Verbot von
Ölheizung Verbot Verbrennermotor Verbot
von SUV Verbot von Autobahnbau Verbot
von Kurzstreckenflügen Verbot von AKW
Verbot von Fracking Verbot von Fleisch
Verbot von Süßigkeiten Nahrung Verbot
von Pflanzenschutzmittel Verbot von
E-Zigaretten Verbot von Böllern Verbot
von Luftballons Verbot von Kitesurfen
Verbot von Tiergarten und so daraus Pony
reiten auf der Wiesen soll verboten
werden liebe Freunde nein nein nein
verboten verboten ich sage Ihnen eines
diese grünen passen nicht zur Bayern und
deswegen wollen wir sie auch nicht in
der bayerischen Staatsregierung haben
ich sage NEIN zu schwarz drin
statt dauert Zoff und Streit in Berlin
haben wir einen regierungsschritte
seriöses gutes Regieren steht bei uns an
erster Stelle deswegen wollen wir die
Kollektion mit unseren Partner der
Freien Wähler fortsetzen es ist nicht
immer einfach das braucht auch manchmal
pädagogisches Geschick und viel Geduld
ja aber es ist am Ende eine gute
bürgerliche Regierung bei der aber klar
ist und die CSU geht nichts voran die
bayern-koalition jedoch ist das
Gegenmodell zu Ampel für Bayern statt
man Platzhalter für Berlin für normale
Bürger und kleine Leute stattfindet
Schnösel Schickeria und wir sind
bodenständig und pragmatisch statt
abgehoben und ideologisch
liebe Freundin Freunde die Bilanz nach
fünf Jahren ist sehr gut wir haben trotz
der Krisen Bayern vorangebracht wir sind
fast überall auf Platz 1 oder Platz 2 in
der länderstatistik wir haben fast alle
Versprechen gehalten und Vorhaben
umgesetzt oder sind im Prozess weit über
90% des Koalitionsvertrages und klar ist
wo wir noch nicht am Ziel sind da
bleiben wir dran zum Beispiel bei der
Barrierefreiheit und natürlich beim
Wohnungsbau es reicht bei weitem noch
nicht aus allerdings muss ich ehrlich
sagen ich wundere mich manchmal wie
andere uns bei dem Thema angreifen also
der Bund hat bei dem Thema doch schon
längst die Segel gestrichen
und selbst die von mir total geliebte
Landeshauptstadt ja also bei den
Skandalen und die eigenen städtischen
Wohnungsbaugesellschaften bin ich echt
beeindruckt mich selbstbewusst Sie uns
dann manchmal tolle Ratschläge geben ich
würde mal vorschlagen der Bund sagt
dafür dass nicht solche bleiben wie bei
KfW stattfinden und die Stadt München
sagt dafür dass Ihre
Wohnungsbaugesellschaft ihre Arbeit
machen und keines Skandale gibt liebe
Freunde
und wir
und wir wir müssen mehr tun Christian an
der Fortsetzung von der Kerstin und
früher vom Hans
die bayernheim hat es acht von 10.000
Wohnungen die versprochen wurden in
Planung und Bau so langsam noch aber es
geht voran aber ich will euch eines
sagen neben dem Bau von Wohnungen in den
Städten gibt es noch einen anderen
Punkten
ich finde die Familien sollen nicht den
Traum vom Eigenheim aufgeben und
begraben müssen
Eigenheim gehört zu Bayern dazu
und ich bin schon wieder beim besten
Finanzminister in Deutschland nämlich
freuen der Albert
aber im schwimmbadprogramm hat er wegen
gezuckt
wir haben einen Vorschlag gemacht wie
wir die Zinsen
günstig
an das ist besser ist als der
marktimmobilien zu kaufen oder zu
erwerben wir gehen sogar weiter wir
geben Bürgschaften für den Ersatz von
Eigenkapital das macht kaum ein
Bundesland der Bund schon gleich gar
nicht warum weil wir eines sagen für uns
ist das Eigenheim wichtiger als der
Plattenbau liebe Freunde der Traum von
einem guten Leben soll bleiben und
möglich sein
das ist unser Angebot das sind unsere
Themen Bayern ist nicht das Paradies ist
schon klar und es liegen übrigens auch
noch schwere Zeiten vor uns
wir tun in diesen Zeiten als
parteifeugnis was wir können wir machen
in Bayern was nur geht landespolitikur
aber viele Weichen Alex werden in Berlin
gestellt deswegen ist unsere Aufgabe
immer zweigleisig ja in Bayern arbeiten
was wir können und in Berlin über den
Bundesrat und über die Landesgruppe
dafür sorgen dass für bayerische
Interessen gekämpft wird die CSU ist die
Stimme Bayerns überall ob in Berlin oder
in Brüssel lieber Manfred lieber
Angelika oton Süd O-Ton Bayern heißt CSU
die anderen Parteien
nun die anderen Parteien in Deutschland
haben entweder Null Ehrgeiz für Bayern
oder 0 Einfluss in Berlin nur wir
kämpfen für bayerische Interessen das
sind übrigens auch die Bürger und Bürger
das zeigen die Umfrage genauso aber
wisst ihr was das nervt die Ampel das
stört die Ampel und deswegen sollten Sie
ihnen manchmal zu laute Stimme Bayerns
zumindest leiser gedreht und einige
wollen sie ganz abdrehen
ich will das mit den neuen Wahlrecht für
die nächste Bundestagswahl bewusst
ansprechen weil es uns als Partei
fundamental aber auch Bayern betrifft
dieses neue Wahlrecht ist ein Skandal
liebe Freunde und Freunde sein einziger
Skandal
wir sind noch nie gegeben lieber Theo
das im Deutschen Bundestag sich eine
Mehrheit eine noch bessere Mehrheit über
das Wahlrecht Zimmern wollte das ist aus
unserer Sicht grob verfassungswidrig das
Demokratieprinzip wird verletzt gab bei
uns in den Städten wählen die Leute
Abgeordneten in München Nürnberg Volk in
Augsburg und bekommen sie dann nach dem
neuen Recht den Abgrund nein anders
das bundesstaatsprinzip wird verletzt
in mit der Streichung der
grundmandatsgrenzen könnte passieren
dass wir alle 46 Wahlkreise gewinnen
aber praktisch kein Bayern Bundestag
sitzt weil es heißt die werden dann
aufgefüllt mit Brandenburgern
schleswig-holsteinen Sachsen-Anhalt
alles ordentliche Leute aber die
Begründung sie sind auf das Grundgesetz
verpflichtet ob das in Bayern reicht
Ludwig Spender hat mich mal darauf
hingewiesen dass seit 1868 schon im
Vorläufer des Reiches immer Vertreter
aus bayerisch regional verankerten
Parteien im Berlin in Bonn oder in
Weimar waren und jetzt soll dann der
Stecker gezogen werden
eines muss ich den Grünen lassen sie
sind wenigstens ehrlich wir haben
Deutschen Bundestag das gesagt was sie
denken sie sagten sie nerve der
bayerische Sonderstatus sie nerve diese
Sonderrolle der CSU und wir wollen jetzt
mal Bayern und die CSU auf das Normalmaß
zur Rechtsschutz
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
draußen an den Firmen man muss Bayern
nicht mögen wir sind auch manchmal eine
ganz einfach gebe zu man muss auch nicht
die CSU mögen man muss sie auch nicht
wählen darf jeder machen will
Millionen Bayern demokratisch
auszuschließen ist ein starkes Stück und
gegen eine gute demokratische Kultur
liebe Freunde
das eine Mal dies eine einzige Mal hatte
ich gehofft dass die ampelparteien im
Landtag einmal Rückgrat haben ein
einziges Mal für Bayern sind was war das
Ergebnis die Grünen springen auf und
klatschten für Berlin die Bayern SPD
verteidigt ist und lobtes die FDP
jammert aber sagt wir ändern das aber
0,0000 Einfluss in Berlin ich sage euch
unsere Antwort wir klagen als
Staatsregierung und CSU
wir klagen in der Gegend
mich haben in einem Chat jetzt Bürger
gefragt was können wir dann dazu tun um
Ihnen zu helfen ich glaube die beste
Hilfe die man machen kann ist im Herbst
ein Signal zu setzen wenn man will dass
Bayern künftig weiter in Berlin stark
vertreten werden soll dann muss man nur
eine Partei wählen und das ist die CSU
stimmen wir für die CD so und diese
Manipulationen zu beenden liebe Freunde
Bayern Bayern ist einfach nicht unsere
Heimat ist einfach ein tolles Land
Bruno Kreisky soll mal gesagt haben
nicht ganz schön er ist eigentlich ganz
gerne in Bayern weil es dann nicht mehr
in Österreich aber noch nicht in
Deutschland hilfe meine Freunde
und wenn alle immer sagen ja aber 13
vielleicht ist unsere Liebe so groß zu
Bayern dass wir manchmal das übertreiben
es mag schon sein und natürlich gibt es
immer was zu verbessern
aber meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren die Bayern Bilanz bis Bayern
Gefühl das stimmt doch wir liegen doch
fast überall ordentlich
und deswegen bitte ich auch dass wir uns
unterhaken nicht mutlos sind im
Gegenteil es werden Sie in diesem
Wahlkampf alle anderen gegen uns
zusammenbinden und es wird zum Teil
schon sehr unter der Gürtellinie seine
mit Unfällen Methoden gearbeitet die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Landtag
sitzen wissen und spüren das jetzt schon
aber davon lassen wir uns nicht mal
ärgern meistens jedenfalls nicht wir
gehen unseren Weg als CSU
ich habe mal überlegt was kann den CSU
alles heißen eigentlich als christlich
Sozialunion aber vielleicht steht das C
auch für charakterstark charismatisch
charmant oder cool
es steht für Sicherheit Stabilität
Solidarität oder stark und das u- ja für
unbeugsam unbequem und umsichtig ich bin
jetzt in diesem Jahr 40 Jahre Mitglieder
CSU persönlich eine ziemlich dramatische
Zahl
ich habe in meinem ganzen Leben nicht
manchmal geärgert über manche
Entscheidungen
vielleicht in einer Parteifreund auch ja
das kennen die alles aber ich habe es
nie bereut Teil dieser großartigen
Gemeinschaft CSU zu sein ich bin stolz
darauf euer Vorsitzender zu sein Stolz
darauf mitreden in dieser Partei zu sein
und arbeiten und leben zu dürfen liebe
Freunde
und ob Weigel stolpers Seehofer
becksteinhuber streibe Strauß Gürtel sie
alle waren nie allein das ist immer eine
große Gemeinschaftsleistung es wird im
idealer Zuspitzung oft vergessen wir
sind ein tolles Team liebevollen Freunde
Staatsregierung Fraktion im Landtag
lieber Thomas die Basis der Partei die
vielen ehrenamtlichen und unsere
kommunalen wir bieten in diesem
Wahlkampf in jedem Regierungsbezirk
außerordentlich kompetente
Spitzenkandidaten in Oberbayern mit Ilse
Aigner unser Landtagspräsidentin liebe
Freunde
in der Oberpfalz mit Albert füracker
liebe Freunde
im schönen Schwaben mit Klaus policek an
der Spitze
in Niederbayern mit Christian dannreiter
als Listenführer
in Ober- und Unterfranken mit Melanie
Hummel und Judith Gerlach an der Spitze
und den kleinen Mittelfranken der
Joachim und nicht so liebe Freunde
und das meine ich jetzt nicht böse bitte
an die Medien nichts falsch verstehen
wenn Sie mit mir jetzt ein Quiz machen
würden und sagen wir steht in der
Oberpfalz an der Spitze der SPD oder der
Grünen wer steht in Schwaben an der
Spitze der FDP wer steht in Unterfranken
an der Spitze von was weiß ich welcher
Partei befürchte nur niederbayerner an
ich während der Spitze unsere
regierungskoalitionspartei stehen kann
ich kenne die anderen Namen nicht und
jetzt zeige ich euch ganz ehrlich wenn
man niemand kennt wieso soll man ihn
dann so vertrauen liebe Freunde und
Freunde wir haben die stärksten
Kandidaten das beste Personal
zum engeren Team Bayern gehört natürlich
auch die Landesleitung generell sehr
stellvertretende Generalsekretärin
Hauptgeschäftsführer und auch in der
Staatskanzlei den Florian Herrmann ist
muss ich einfach sagen weil er auch
gerade während der corona-zeit er war
der Doktor Sommer der CSU der konnte
jede Frage beantworten der kann dir jede
Verordnung euch allen Martin Flo
herzliches Dankeschön dafür
und danke auch Anja Weisgerber und
Gerhard Hopp für das neue
Grundsatzprogramm des wir anschließend
beschließen mir gefällt der Titel für
ein neues Miteinander ich finde man
erkennt ein bisschen im Unterschied zum
letzten es ist die Ordnung es war zwar
zum ersten Moment sympathisch weil es
klar nachdem nach einer Organisation aus
dem Star Wars Universum aber nicht so
den besten
mir gefällt dieser Titel denn für ein
neues Miteinander ist einladend umarmen
und mitfühlt
liebe Freunde wir wollen am 8 oktober
bei Lampen bezirkstagswahl erfolgreich
sein wir wollen unsere Arbeit fortsetzen
gerne auch ein bisschen mehr als 2018
ohne dabei zu träumen oder abzuheben
und zum Schluss ein persönliches
Bekenntnis ich bin jetzt selbst fünf
Jahre als Ministerpräsidentin Amt es war
sehr sehr spannende Jahre ich habe viel
gelernt und wurde ist glaube ich kann
nicht sagen hat geprüft
ich bin hoffentlich reifer geworden in
der Zeit vielleicht auch gelassener
natürlich macht man weiter Fehler aber
aus jedem Fehler lernt man ich setze
mehr und das habe ich gelernt mir auf
Team als je zuvor ich bekomme jetzt
dieser Tage interessante Vorwürfe wer in
der corona-zeit hieß es ich sei zu wenig
empathisch und zu nah am Bürger jetzt
bekomme ich den Vorwurf der dauernd
unterwegs
deshalb bei den Bürgern so
übrigens interessanterweise wenn
oppositionsabgeordnete da sind bekomme
ich nicht annähernd die Chance die zwei
Zentimeter von mir an so einem Termin zu
halten
weil ich die noch nie irgendwo gesehen
habe
ich bekenne mich ja ich und mir wir sind
gern bei den Menschen draußen uns
interessiert was die Menschen denken und
fühlen wir kümmern uns um die großen
Linien aber auch die kleine Politik
jeder einzelne ist uns wichtig
ich selbst bin mit meiner ganzen Energie
und zum Glück ist die ganz ordentlich
rund um die Uhr für Bayern im Einsatz
ich war bin und werde begeistert sein
wie schön Bayern ist und was für
großartige Bürger und Bürger mit diesem
großartigen ehrenamtlichen Engagement
haben
ich will das Fortsetzen hier gehöre ich
her
einmal Berlin reicht
ich will ein gutes Miteinander mit der
CDU bitte Friedrich und allen anderen
melden ja wir setzen auf ein gutes
Miteinander das ist uns wichtig meine
unser Lebensaufgabe ist Bayern liebe
Freunde und Freunde ich will mit Euch
beiden eine gute Zukunft führen ich will
das Beste für Bayern erreichen lasst uns
bitte gemeinsam unsere Arbeit für das
Land fortsetzen für neues Miteinander in
Bayern und der CSU lasst uns die Stürme
der Zeit durchstehen und dabei allen so
viel wie möglich mitnehmen wir
überlassen Bayern nicht den linken
Bayern soll Bayern
dafür stehe ich ganz persönlich und wenn
ihr wollt auch als Spitzenkandidat ich
bitte um eure Unterstützung gott schütze
Bayern gott schütze den sie so auf
geht's so in den Wahlkampf Leben Freunde
auf geht's
ja meine Damen und Herren das war die
Rede des Parteivorsitzenden Markus Söder
ich lasse sie mit den
klatschaktionen noch mal ein bisschen
alleine weil das immer der Gradmesser
ist für die Zustimmung eines
Parteivorsitzenden das heißt wie lange
wird geklatscht stehen sie ja sie stehen
sie sehen das an den Bildern und jetzt
erntet er den Erfolg den er durch seine
Rede
erarbeitet hat wie groß die nachhaltig
der Erfolg ist wird man sehen aber die
Tatsache dass die Delegierten
aufgestanden sind und jetzt stehend
Ovationen für diese Rede
haben und mit ihm das als Reaktion
abfeiern das lassen wir jetzt erstmal
stehen
sie sehen ich zähle mit seit ungefähr 30
Sekunden ist der Ablauf so wie er jetzt
ist
zieht sich gleich gerade meiner Kenntnis
wie lange der längste Applaus für einen
Parteivorsitzenden der CSU gewesen ist
aber dies ist nach einer Stunde 38 die
Markus Söder hier geredet hat sein
Applaus
[Applaus]
[Musik]